lui c'est l'homme de verre à cause d'une
maladie congénitale seo se cassent comme
du cristal c'est pour cela que tous ces
meubles sont molletonné la maladie de
l'homme de verre dans amélie poulain
c'est l'ostéogénèse imparfaite et c'est
avec elle que vit khadija shogi depuis
25 ans la moindre ace sur son jeu me
fracture est faite a indiqué mais mes
parents ne vais pas me prendre dans
leurs bras mais à travers une planche
pour pas me manipuler d'étrave à 15 ans
de recherche dans les laboratoires de
l'hôpital pour enfants de montréal
pourrait tout changer
rené st-arnaud s'intéresse au rôle de la
vitamine d dans la réparation des eaux
la vitamine d sont molécules inactive il
faut qu'elle soit transformée deux fois
avant de devenir une forme hormonal les
gens ont toujours considéré que ce meta
beauce ce métabolite était une forme
inactive mais pas l'équipe du docteur
st-arnaud ya une raison pour laquelle
dakar cet été cette molécule d'eau s'est
pas loupé pour rien et les résultats sur
les souris sont très encourageants la
molécule accélère la consolidation d'une
fracture et la rend plus efficace voici
une réparation sans la molécule on voit
bien que la taille de cette structure
est beaucoup plus petit et au même temps
de réparation la facture n'a pas encore
commencé à préparer complètement
et quand on sait qu'il y a près d'un
million de fractures chaque année au
canada et 10 % qui guérissent mal les
applications pourraient être vaste on
peut passer à l'ostéoporose par exemple
les passagers réussir et à facturer et
c'est toujours des fractures complexes
et il y a plus complexe encore comme la
maladie de khadidja c'est pas une
fraîcheur une femme est inventé c'est
quelque chose de très jeunes gens
n'étaient qu'une centaine d'infractions
j'ai plus fait le concours est bien
franche avec vous mais si un enfant
avait la solution mais râble pour
pouvoir guérir plus rapidement et plus
efficacement
je pense réellement que ça milliards et
sa caisse fc pour améliorer sa qualité
de vie
reste maintenant à passer des souris aux
patients peut-être dès l'année prochaine
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal